it is considered one of the most
effective covit 19 vaccines now
scientists say they've
hacked the genetics sequence behind
modena's revolutionary mrna vaccine and
shared the code with the world
online for free the stanford university
researchers sequenced modernist patented
drug by
studying leftover vaccine vials with
permission from u.s
authorities mrna is the key mechanism
used in the vaccine it triggers the
body's
own cells to produce the protein needed
to defeat the corona virus
now dw's amir isif has been following
this
story for us amir does this mean we can
all start mixing our own
vaccine at home very soon no
unfortunately not it may seem that way
given
where they posted this to github which
is a place that has garnered attention
for being a kind of hacktivist website
where activists can post reverse
engineered computer software codes that
people can download it
for free and in the public good and so
these scientists posted
their code which is mrna code a
biological code not a computer code
onto this website but mrna is a complex
biological product
that can't be downloaded like a computer
program involves a huge supply chain and
there's
even some steps involving nano particles
that only a few hundred people
in the world even know how to do let
alone have the option to do that
with the help of a big company like
modernist so we're not going to see any
home brewed vaccines anytime soon i
don't think
unfortunately i'd be one of the first to
try uh
what was what's behind this project then
well their uh explanation was just as
simple they said that this is a
biological component
that exists now in a pretty big part of
the human population and
they say researchers have a right to
know what it looks like
so they've found out what the code was
using
just leftover material in these vaccine
vials and post it online because they
said
uh in particular people who are
researching covet 19
should be able to distinguish between
what mrna is coming from the human body
what is coming from a virus
and then what is coming from this
particular synthetic
mrna sequence well this sequence
is it not modernis intellectual property
have they said anything in reaction
well it is and it isn't it's their
intellectual property to create it
but just to know what it is it's like if
you took a microscope and you looked at
a bmw what are the components of the car
so that's all these scientists did they
said here's what we found this is how
it's made
but moderna has actually been pretty
lacks in going after
copyright violations patent violations
they've even the president of the
company gave an interview and said that
they're not going to
go after patent violations and the
scientists notified moderna
before they did this and there was no
protest from the company
our reporter amir asif thank you